being in Berlin with Conan were you
embarrassed at all to have Conan with
you I mean did you worry he was going to
embarrass you in front of other Germans
this sounds like something he has done
to you as you're asking me about it
yes all of this one
right everyone loved him there was a big
big Crush yes yes yes he was walking
around like one of the Direction boys
let's try so what do they call it
correct direction what direction yes yes
he it's like it's a tall red head man
from correct direction was walking
around and everyone was making a freak
out
so you think people could tell that he
was famous or because I don't think a
lot of people recognized him Conan has a
famous walk you know he is a walk of I
know my IMDb score is pretty low
and people can smell it how did you
perceive that Germans
um thought of Conan well there was one
he had a fight with someone who was
telling him about a spell check issue
with one of the episodes do you remember
like an argument about a factual era oh
yes during one of the things yeah that
guy had driven three hours did he say he
was from I remember nothing only that he
disagreed and I felt this is the most
German man on the street encounter I can
imagine yes yes it was wonderful I found
a lot more arrows arrows I mean
[Applause]
[Music]
you find a lot of mistakes on our show
yeah
I traveled two hours to give me these
mistakes it almost three years three
hours from Bavaria
and uh you you tournaments we mean
business yeah you do me in business
yeah those are my speaking very quickly
you just felt like someone that you put
the way I listened to a lot of podcasts
at 1.25 speed right with him yeah that
was him yes yes yes I love that guy in
Germany because he those are my favorite
um people we encounter where there's no
warning and they just come up upon them
yeah and I I hopefully the cameras are
rolling yes yes that's true they always
were and they're not Were You There When
when we read because I know you dipped
in you only dipped in and out so what
did you do yes we were jealous of you
because we we'd go you know we'd have a
nice lunch review where you talk on some
German terms which was hilarious and
then we'd take we'd go off do other
stuff for a day and then we'd meet back
up with you like go to the nude beach
and I I was just jealous I'm like that
yeah bastard is having a great getting
massages yeah what are you up to I have
a three event rotation in my day so I
tried to hit very close
shout out shout out Garden State yeah
not the film with Natalie Portman no the
boys
what's he called the situation oh
situations
yes
event one calisthenics and then two uh
exchange rate uh manipulation
if you there are some banks that offered
slightly but this was uh not yet this is
pretty crypto for me I have dived into
that hole let me tell you shout out Doge
[Music]
so yeah I would make small amounts of
money by exchanging money from one part
of the city to the other okay but do you
have you have to pay fees though every
time but if you walk you're safe on
Transportation or you can get a day pass
and so you can travel as many times as
you like on the uban German for Subway
okay so you're just exchanging
marks what's that well shout out to
1998.
that's it right it's the European Union
um no it's funny I was like oh uh I I
would I missed the finish in people's
shame because it's now the scent in I'm
in Germany so it's fine I feel I feel
your pains oh and the third thing was
just staring as all Germans do yes yeah
that's the third of your day yes
yes you stare at people or yeah is
staring not considered rude in Germany
it's considered curiosity it doesn't
kill anything you know here kills
kittens apparently in Germany it just
broadens your horizons when you stare is
there an expectation to follow it up
with a question a query of some kind or
just staring by itself is fine staring
means nothing but Americans and everyone
thinks it means something weird or
perhaps a threatening but the German is
just like my eyes are open you are here
I'm taking you in like a delicious
Gatorade yeah and what happens if
someone stares back do you just lock
eyes for a long time nobody knows you
have to get married it's never happened
no it's not even a locking it's not like
what happens when the Ghostbuster
streams crosses I'm just looking and
taking it in I did not know about German
still I want to go back to Germany I
want to look out for the stairs oh so
much so many that's all we do
what's the German word for staring which
just means hey no it's not even rude you
know it's sound staring it's like why
are you staring yeah German sweat don't
say that you're like oh hi your eyes are
open and is it anywhere like an elevator
Subway nude beach oh it's Autobahn all
the places Universal yeah Universal yeah
yeah it's like donuts in America and is
there a distant like is it usually
people have to be at least oh like 10
feet away or close by you can just stare
like a Bette Midler from a distance yes
it's like a Bette Midler yeah the word
looks blue and green you can be as close
as you'd like as far as you like
sometimes it's just blurry if you have
enough stigmatism right then you're just
looking at a Magic Eye poster correct or
you're having a stroke
and you can stare at any part of the
person right oh like down up everywhere
sure yeah yeah certainly yes yeah we
don't care okay yeah yeah it just you're
here you're out you're public you're in
public yeah so you are now my property
it's like Olive Garden when you hear
your family except when you're here
nobody cares keep staring
yeah are there why are there any German
chain restaurants uh we have stolen some
Pizza Hut Pizza Hut yeah but it's like
that was a very nice wonderful
restaurant where it was very expensive
and only the deepest of dishes oh so
it's a fancy restaurant yes oh that I
mean that's I know in France McDonald's
is a nicer thing is this true yes oh
well McDonald's you must pay for your
ketchup what yes is that true oh yes you
pay for condiments was it what you heard
me
what about mustard that seems illegal to
have to pay for mustard I never
purchased mustard so I cannot confirm it
or deny it I know people bring their own
mustard
uh oh byom yes
I've heard of this yes but uh mainly
people will purchase okay yeah you get
you get patted down you have to it's
like going into a baseball game you know
there's a little bit of an x-ray before
you go oh yeah they don't want you okay
I understand no outside mustard only
that Hometown stuff